so you know speaking of you know
promiscuous women in the media Brittany
Renner who was a guest on our show about
six to eight months ago gives Charleston
white a lap dance and throws water on
him during a podcast so when Britney was
here a couple of months ago she
expressed that she really regretted a
lot of the men that she slept with and a
lot of the decisions she made and people
that I shared my body with when I think
about my list
it's repulsive
because they didn't deserve it but that
was an outcome of me discounting my
worth and
it's disgusting
um I hate even having that spiritual tie
in any type of way but yeah I would
absolutely change sexually how I move
around